bonsoir gérald anisé merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on le voit
la pression monte assure andrew cuomo
est ce qu'il peut tenir à son poste au
moins le temps de l'enquète oui bonsoir
vous avez raison la pression monte mais
pour l'instant c'est surtout une
pression médiatique et j'aurais quand
même insisté sur un fait c'est qu'il ya
des accusations qui pèsent contre lui
mais même aux etats-unis aujourd'hui
pour l'instant tant qu'il n'y a pas eu
procès tant qu'il n'y a pas eu jugement
tant qu'il n'y a pas eu condamnation
toute personne est présumée innocente
jusqu'à avoir été trouvé coupable
donc pour moi ces allégations même si
elles sont vraies et elles sont très
probablement avéré parce qu'elle a
suffisamment maintenant pour que ya une
certaine cohérence autour de tout cela
mais elle ne devrait pas suffire à faire
que le gouverneur démissionne il me
semble beaucoup plus graves par exemple
ce qui s'est passé concernant sa gestion
de la pandémie de co vide et notamment
le fait qu' il ait délibérément caché au
public la réalité du nombre des décès
notamment dans les ehpad de l'état de
new york
ça c'est une faute je dirais
administrative qui est beaucoup plus
grave et qui d'ailleurs est en train de
susciter de la part de certains de ses
adversaires
une démarche dinkic bonne comme l'a
souligné votre reportage donc en gros
comment est manifestement en grande
difficulté ils pourraient ils pourraient
abandonner en démissionnant
immédiatement pour moi il n'est pas
encore acculé d'olivier pourtant
pourtant joe biden et nancy pelosi on
l'a vu sont pas dans l'embarras mais en
tout cas botton touchant il n'y a pas
vraiment
voilà de la charge du démocrate comeau
qui restent dans les rangs du parti
démocrate et qui reste tout de même
d'une certaine manière soutenue tout à
fait vous avez parfaitement raison mais
en même temps ce n'est pas à eux de le
faire ce n'est pas leur rôle
et ce serait une situation très
embarrassante
on va dire que les les démocrates sont
beaucoup plus embarrassé qu'il ne paraît
par cette situation
ils sont pour l'instant protégé par une
presse qui en dehors de new york n'est
pas totalement contre leur propre camp
qui en tous les cas ne cherche pas à
prétendre que ce qui est arrivé ou ceux
qui arrivent à andrew cuomo ou ceux dont
andrew comme au 1er responsable
représente exactement l'attitude de tous
les personnages politiques démocrates
donc pour l'instant à washington on
cherche surtout comme vous dites a botté
en touche
c'est à dire à ne pas s'impliquer dans
un sens ou dans un autre
à ne pas prononcer une parole qui
pourrait dans quelques jours ou dans
quelques semaines avoir des conséquences
qu'on imagine pas aujourd'hui alors
andrew cuomo lui se défend avec vigueur
assurant que les allégations contre lui
sont fausses et laissant entendre qu'il
était une nouvelle victime
je cite de la cun cette culture qui fait
rage actuellement aux etats unis
l'argument de cancelles cultura on
rappelle pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient 1
qui pousse son retrait en gros de la
sphère publique de personnalités jugées
coupables d'abus ou discrimination
contre les minorités sexuelles ou
ethnique
cet argument est ce qu'ils les entendent
abs que justement il illustre le clivage
au sein d'eads et du parti démocrate
alors pour moi le cac locomo ce n'est
pas de la can son coach le cac ou homo
c'est les conséquences du mit tout
mouvement
c'est à dire le mythe ou mouvements vous
vous souvenez qui est née avec la ferme
einstein ou ce grand producteur de
hollywood a été accusé de viol de
harcèlement sexuel par par plusieurs
femmes des faits qui remontaient à très
longtemps mais qui s'était produit sur
une très longue durée et sur lesquels
beaucoup de gens avaient
alors fermez les yeux depuis ce moment
là dès qu'on a une à l'ogre une commande
irène allégations de harcèlement sexuel
et bien la personne visée est supposé en
effet se retirer immédiatement
donc elle est condamnée avant qu'il y
ait jugement c'est ça d'ailleurs que je
critiquais en tout début de mon
intervention quand j'ai répondu à votre
première question
ça c'est le mouvement oui tout dont il
est question lorsque rendre vos mots
parlent de cannes son coach la can son
coach je regrette c'est autre chose
la can son coach c'est le fait d
d'éliminer de marginaliser toute pensée
dissidente vis à vis d'un certain nombre
de principes qui aujourd'hui régis là on
va dire notre la pensée progressiste et
c'est faire en sorte notamment que toute
pensée conservatrice et tous les
républicains et tous les supporters de
30 soit immédiatement targuer de raciste
de suprémaciste blanc est donc mis hors
du champ politique la can sans coach
c'est ça la can sont encore sur consiste
à éliminer les personnes qui sont en
désaccord avec vous sans pour autant
avoir d'une manière ou d'une autre fauté
alors que là les allégations qui
concerne le gouverneur comme au son des
allégations très graves aussi bien d'un
point de vue administrative parce qu'il
aurait quand même menti il a dissimulé
un certain nombre de faits concernant la
pandémie
et puis après des accusations qui
portent sur un comportement personnel ce
n'est pas du même niveau mais c'est tout
aussi grave
mais ces fautes je dirais de
comportement nécessite qu'il n'y a eu
une enquête et pas simplement une
accusation et qu'à partir d'une
accusation
une personne se retrouve immédiatement
détruites ça c'est un petit peu exagéré
quand même alors il ya une femme qui va
jouer un rôle important et c'est
d'ailleurs le point commun entre andrew
cuomo et donald trump
letitia james à la procureur général de
l'état de new york qui a en ligne de
mire d'ailleurs les deux hommes qui
semble d'une certaine manière
intouchable ce qu'elle peut les obliger
letitia james rendent des comptes alors
elle a un rôle très important et elle a
beaucoup de pouvoir parce que aux états
unis le procureur est la personne qui je
dirais dirige les affaires
néanmoins elle à elle doit faire je
dirais non pas attention mais il faut
qu'elle s'assure que son dossier soit je
dirais blindés parce que malgré tout le
gouverneur de new york
c'est pas le premier quidam venu et
encore une fois il y à un système
politique qui le protège c'est à dire
que tant qu'il n'a pas été condamné par
une cour de justice
il n'est tenu à rien sur le plan
politique
donc elle a beaucoup de pouvoir contre
lui elle a beaucoup de pouvoirs dans ce
dossier mais c'est à elle de bien gérer
merci beaucoup gérald olivier chercheur
à l'institut de prospective et de
sécurité en europe journaliste prend
quoi mais qui remercie d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france